top 50
followed people on instagram i think for
the majority
it's probably really famous people but
yeah when you get to like say top
thousand
there's gonna be somebody gonna be like
why does this [ __ ] have 20
followers you know you're gonna you know
it's like people you're just not going
to know
we know all those we know all those yeah
so that's top that's top 10 right there
so now 11.
you start to go you go where's my boy
snoop nike
katy perry i would think the first 50
for the most part
oh okay i get that but look at that look
at the numbers where is snooze
number 42 though let's go all right i'm
just saying though you're talking that's
the 50 well i don't even know who
but who that is so you go top 100 but
like yeah like you're talking about
50 million people
yeah follow this one follow this person
yeah so like if you
were so you're so you could be your own
company let's say you said
yeah all those people you said hey can
you can you like give me 10 cents each
yeah i mean damn that's a lot that's a
lot of money
i don't know like i've never seen this
person before i don't even know where
she is i don't know who she
is what's in her description she's got a
50 million reach now how's that
engagement
that's the no you know how you do go to
one of her pictures yeah let's see if
it's
one of her pictures okay no no i'm
saying you look at the how many likes on
this picture so it has almost
almost a million that's the real
engagement yeah yeah so it's like you
know you have
well she just posted a couple hours ago
but but you know also
so if she has 50 million uh followers
instagram limits how many people see
that post so if she posts that what
yeah you have to pay to promote it
that's that's
the instagram's [ __ ] up thing so let's
you know i have whatever but if you have
that
i have like whatever 1.4 million if i
post some 1.4 million
but if you post that one point it's not
going to go to 1.4 million you have to
pay
to get those other people to see it to
promote it
damn well how [ __ ] up is that well
okay it's a business
advocacy yeah let's go ahead go ahead
all right so i'm a company
right you're an international i'm
instagram you're the head of and i
provide a service
where you can reach 50 million people
yeah and and
and because you reach those 50 million
people you can now generate
revenue beyond your wildest dreams
really
yeah because like you should be on there
being like you know swiping under water
guys
and you're making a hundred thousand
dollars a month you're making all this
money
right yeah hello i provided this service
yeah yeah
i got you i got it i think that's fair
yeah i provided this uh so
yeah so maybe i collected all the people
for you
um pay me for it yeah i have no problem
with that interesting well unlike when
you build a website you got to pay to
build
your website domain now i have no
problem with
instagram you don't have a problem with
that making money
from providing this service run ads on
my post no no bad but for but you're
so if i accumulate 2 million followers i
don't have access to 2 million unless i
pay you
but those 2 million are following me for
a reason but i provide it's just like a
comedy club bro
explain it's a business the comedy clubs
they're getting drink money and all that
kind of stuff right but that's what i'm
talking about but that's on instagram
they're getting part of the like when
you go to a comedy club yeah but i don't
go to the comm club hey make sure you're
charging this much for bear make sure
it's two drink minimum no no but when
you go to a comic club
and it takes 30 dollars you're not
getting that whole 30 dollars
no okay why because they're saying this
is my building
uh i pro i'm providing you with the
seats in space
even though the people are coming for
you yeah i provided all this
i'm getting some money for that that's
what that's what instagram they're doing
they're just getting their cut
but they i feel like they could get
their cut somewhere else like run
ads on my page where the [ __ ] you want
and sell that across the board
but i have to take out of my own money
yeah because i'm saying
it's a different animal but when people
stick with you if you're if
instagram is running ads yeah see the
beauty
the whole thing about it is like let me
ask you this you have the food
i can't believe you
[Music]
like the reason why is twitter and
instagram is free yeah it's because
nobody's going to pay for that [ __ ]
exactly yeah but they're but but
instagram and twitter
billion dollar companies yeah but they
are a billion dollars but they're a
billion dollar companies because
they like like google like
google charges people like if you look
like like google like
anything like thai restaurants all right
all right you get a bunch of ads with
taiwan's
first five or whatever it is paid for
these are going to be paid for
at the top you know like you know
whatever the things are they're going to
be paid and yeah
look at the results it's going to be
like these paid they're so unpaid to be
in the right
right yeah because they're saying look
we're providing the thing
that everyone uses yes exactly to search
can we get a little bit that's it so i'm
just being
i'm just being the devil advocate of
this i don't have a problem with
free services saying to the people hey
you can pay me to get these you got a
million followers so so we've
we've granted yesterday it's like when
you go to like a fair like a book fair
or like let's say you're like you you
one of those crafts and service
markets or whatever right and you you
you make like you know
you make masks or something you know and
then they have
they make you pay for the booth
and why do they make you pay for the
booth because they
they've invited thousands of people to
come and buy your
buy your goods yeah so you have to pay
for that booth
so so how much should instagram charge
do you what's fair to them
well i mean i don't know i don't know
what you know because i've boosted
you know when you know when you go to
like a town and you're like oh i got a
boost to like
get people to come and i picked the
algorithm i do facebook ads
yeah but what i'm saying is how much
money do you think they should make
like do you think they shouldn't make
money they're already making money but
that's how they're making money yeah
this is what i was going to say isn't it
yeah that's
no idea those are they making money like
i get it if you think about it yeah
but let me let me know but but this but
this run servers
i know it's a nightmare okay i just had
this conversation about starting their
own platform and we're talking about
you know how youtube like if you're
going to build a
show like a network like that just the
bandwidth you'd pay for it let's say if
your podcast gets a million downloads on
video
just the bandwidth would cost you a [ __ ]
ton which we don't have to pay for on
youtube
so run your ads yeah you run your ads i
get it
but so that's one thing but i'm saying
something that is like but did you did
you know instagram does that
it's not like you're not out there i
don't know well well we know kim
kardashian get paid like what a million
dollars
for a swipe up all right so exactly so
on instagram i'm like damn so i
i i wrangled i provided a service
where a hundred million people
can reach you can reach you yeah they
should get paid
i i get you i get you it's like the
middleman you the middleman won his cut
my problem is what's the cut what and
i'm saying to you
and also be be
[Applause]
yeah yeah
my problem with this area it's not it's
not tran it's not transparent like let
me know okay
well if i pay this much i'll reach all
my followers i have no [ __ ]
yeah um
when i go to a place and
they they you know if i'm not selling
the place out
if i'm not changing the ticket price
because of my popularity
you know it's case by case
there are some comics that they're going
to go and they're going to get 80 cut 80
of the door and they're going to add
shows
you know it's because of that's that's
the so that's the demand demand that's
the demand
yeah so this person is going to make
money and the club makes money
yeah like the club makes more money off
of
huge acts because it's 50 a ticket
and they get selling all this food where
it's tricky for them is when they make
deals like that with someone that
they're not
sure if they're going to make the money
or not and they're guaranteed a certain
money
they don't like doing that you know so
with instagram
you know it's like all right that's
still a lot of people
1.4 million people is a lot of people is
that what it is cat i don't know 1.2
all right look at that oh that's all
right
i don't know we got eric claire
i'm covered
so let's say let's say okay so kim
kardashian has 100 million
and that girl has 50 million is it
there's a
instagram charge like do they very like
yo let's say that's the interesting
question
there's no transparency i have no
questions does kim kardashian promote
like does she go like promote please
yeah yeah but what i'm saying is if it's
a different price but if it's the same
price
as me instagram ain't making enough
money exactly so that's my point yeah
i'll give it to you
like even if she said i'll pay 5 000 to
promote this to all 100 million people
it's completely worth it to her because
if she's gonna get
if she like 100 million people yeah yeah
she says look at the name yeah i'll um
and actually she can charge the company
i was just about to say you know you got
to pay me
five grand on top and that goes to my
cost of promoting this that's what she
i'm saying is like all i'm saying is
like i really again i really have no
problem with
everybody wants you for free man
everybody thinks like because the
problem is i need transparency is what
i'm saying
all right that's different from saying
that they don't deserve the money yeah
because at first you were like why are
they charging as if they shouldn't make
money their business
yeah their business but there needs to
be transparency if there's 1.2 million
followers
all 1.2 should see every post no but let
me know
let me know how much it is that's
it's just a matter of the order that it
goes in because they stopped doing
chronological order so it's not like
if you post a photo right now some
people may see it right now some people
may not see it until they scroll even
further down it's not gonna be the first
thing that pops up unless they engage
with your account a lot that's the
algorithm
so it's still there because it's harder
to find some people like your posts from
two days later
and they just oh i didn't know you post
like the algorithm is crazy and like you
said it's the fact that instagram worth
their money
so they want to you want to broadcast
this post no i get it it's like what's
crazy to me is how many
males are doing only fans now well the
rise of only fantasy
is going up by chris brown just signed
up yeah i know brown just did an ole fan
bro
you know what this is like it's like
when when lady gaga no one i'm sorry
when britney spears went to vegas
they made fun of her at first they made
fun of her at first yeah then they said
oh you made a hundred million dollars
you know now every motherfucker's in
vegas now yeah i'm doing the race
jennifer lopez yeah everybody's in vegas
beyonce everybody gets a stigma to it
right
oh these are the males that are only
fans just just 14 different accounts
celebrities that are on yeah and that's
why not and you can do different things
like why not but i'm saying
here's what's wrong sonia moore for
housewives yeah listen here's what's
wrong
here's what here's my problem with
instagram and this would change the
whole game
like this is what's like oh here yeah
i'm not surprised
because you the only fans used to be a
sad thing yeah now it's kind of a pop oh
yeah
better thorn she just made it popular so
now here's the problem so now all these
like regular chicks out here on only
fans
because by the way this uh like reels
i'm talking about on instagram yeah
like people need to get hit to that you
don't need only fans there's like
there's girls out there practically
giving it away
just for free on instagram yeah but if
you want to get your rocks off with a
girl that
you know is a real person just go to
instagram but anyway here's my problem
with
here's how instagram can again take over
even beating only fans
wait what monetize that's all they gotta
do
that's what facebook does so you have a
video on facebook
and it gets 19 million views like that
that one comic something country country
winning country when he blew up
no no the black guy not the black guy oh
i'm talking about the white guy that got
clowned in
uh uh jfl um darren oh the guy
uh gosh what is that guy's name darren
carter no no no no i'm not dear carter
oh my god
hold on damn right night night oh okay
wait wait wait wait
no no no no southern mama this guy this
guy wait what this guy makes
millions of dollars a year off facebook
dude
doing what just being a fool you know
just doing little funny videos he's a
comic he just makes a little funny
funny he became
what i'm saying is all is and they're
starting to do it now you know they have
this thing on instagram called badges
oh yeah now when you go live people can
tip you
what yeah because you're trying to knock
out only fans now
all i'm saying is this is what you
should do it's just it's just
monetize profiles yeah so if you do
video
and it gets a million views now now they
can put commercials in it yes
okay and then you monetize so you're a
million people then they'll be like okay
we'll let all your million people watch
yeah
because if a million people watch this
we may know that a million people saw
this commercial that's what's next with
instagram and then it's not gonna be a
problem
but what they're saying to you is we're
providing a free
unmolested service there's no
advertising on it
because we want you we want to have that
sort of coolness of
this is free and you get to talk to your
favorite ufc fighter
podcaster yeah right yeah
but they're like but we don't make no
money and we got to pay a million
dollars a month to
to uh google amazon to host our
our [ __ ] you know that's just expensive
man you're talking about the server
space
so expensive you know it's really
expensive you know so they're like hey
we're not making any money so how do we
make money charge them we're charging
you
because we're you're paying for this
free service that we have all these
people looking at you
and again i'm just looking at it from a
different perspective people hate ads
though
it's like do you do you have spotify do
you have everyone has spotify
yeah sometimes when you try and listen
to a song and there's three ads before
my song i'm like what
what you want to turn it off yeah that's
why wait check this out
so you know what people do what they do
pay for it they pay for it that's why
they do it oh
yeah that's how they do it but if you
don't my point is if you don't
they're going to get theirs and they put
all these ads in the front step
so then you have to pay this is going to
be the next step that's a shock
instagram
and they say if you don't want to add
pay it costs a dollar a month
uh wait what what's up but that's the
next that's the next step
that would be the smart thing to do
because people were like yeah i'm sick
these [ __ ] ads it's kind of like
youtube red or it's kind of like yeah
the fans find out who they like they pay
five dollars what the [ __ ] you want to
charge
and it's all ad free just the content
but don't and you can't really get
cancelled on page but those people also
patreon's making money because they're
charging a fee yeah well they take they
they
but they should right they should
because of the bandwidth and everything
i'm with you i'm
saying i'm gonna say to you i'm with
facebook instagram should get their cut
here's my problem though when i when i
uh because i have to do a patreon with
king and the sting
so when i signed up for it it shows hey
we charge this month
this much cool you guys doing as a
service that makes sense with instagram
i have no [ __ ] clue
there's no transparency yeah who are you
gonna talk because it's you know what it
is because it's like growing
it just keeps changing changing and it's
like if you could just send an email
like hey you want to reach this many
people it costs this much like all right
cool yeah charge me that man
but i like we live in a capitalist
society and you're capitalizing on that
because like that million people that
follow you it translates into other
things
you have a huge following on this a blue
check you know when you go out on
youtube it's my lifeline it's your life
you know so it's like and they're saying
we know it's your lifeline yeah i know i
get it no i get it right
yeah also like the mob dude
the business is like are you doing good
here this is good
yeah you know it's 20 right
give me a little taste they don't give a
[ __ ] if you go anywhere else
three when they were like you know you
give us a little on that podium though
you're with the pulpit yeah i remember
that
i mean give us a little bit that's a
mafia
yeah it's a little you know i totally
get it so i don't know